en el vídeo pasado estábamos hablando
acerca de una deuda nos vamos a endeudar
con un banco con una cantidad de dinero
open y lo que nosotros queríamos saber
era de una manera continua qué cantidad
de dinero y vamos a de ver si teníamos
una tasa de interés del 10 por ciento es
decir errebal día el 10% es mi tasa de
interés y en este caso en donde el
tiempo es continuo es decir supongamos
que tengo un año y lo divido en
trillones de trillones de trillones de
partes entonces la fórmula para saber
cuánto íbamos a deber
estaba dada por p que multiplica a
elevado a la r y esta fórmula estaba
pensada para el primer año pero como es
un interés compuesto vamos a ver qué es
lo que pasa si yo pido prestado de pesos
por lo tanto después del primer año yo
voy a ver pp por la r esto en pesos y
esto se deduce por la fórmula de la que
hemos estado hablando ahora qué pasa en
el segundo año bueno en el segundo año
empezamos con una deuda de por al aire
es decir se pone al aire se convierte en
nuestro capital o si lo queremos ver en
nuestra deuda inicial para el segundo
año por
siguiendo otra vez la fórmula este sería
ahora nuestra pe y hay que multiplicarlo
por la r es decir esta es la cantidad
que debemos y lo multiplicamos por ella
la r y de hecho esto es lo mismo que por
el lado cr y al aire por el aire me da a
la 2 r y bueno esto es en el segundo año
para el tercer año pasaría lo mismo
empezaremos con una deuda de por el lado
serial multiplicarlo por el aire me va a
dar p por a la 3 r y así sucesivamente
para cualquier año de hecho podemos
decir que en el año te vamos a dar de
ver por el reporte es decir p por el
elevado a la rtp donde t es la cantidad
de años que han pasado y bueno si hasta
aquí queda claro todo lo que estamos
haciendo no vas a tener ningún problema
de saber cuánto le vas a deber al banco
después de una cierta cantidad de tiempo
así que mejor vamos a verlo con un este
por un ejemplo particular supongamos que
yo le pido prestado al banco mil pesos
yo le pido prestado el banco mil pesos y
el banco tiene una tasa de interés no sé
del 25 por ciento esta es mi tasa de
interés este es r y escrito en forma
decimales punto 25 y yo me tardo en
pagar estos mil pesos tres años cuánto
voy a deberle al banco después de tres
años entonces para resolver esta
pregunta es lo que voy a hacer es
utilizar la fórmula que ya sabía
utilizar la fórmula que habíamos sacado
hace rato recuerda que tenemos un
interés compuesto continuo en el tiempo
por lo tanto lo que voy a deberle son
los mil pesos iniciales que multiplica a
elevado a la tasa de interés que es
punto 25 por el tiempo por el tiempo
bueno el tiempo vamos a tachar lo vamos
a poner una vez 3 entonces yo lo que
quiero saber es cuánto es 1000 por el
elevado al punto 75 y para eso voy a
utilizar otra vez excel
entonces aquí voy a poner igual a 1000
mil es mi capital inicial 1000 es mi
deuda inicial que multiplica y para
poner el elevado a una potencia en excel
hay que poner exp
a qué número apuntó 75 esto está
diciendo que es 1000 por el elevado al
punto 75 y esto me dará el resultado
donde tengo mi resultado mis resultados
este de aquí que no se ve nada entonces
lo voy a hacer más grande voy a subirle
un poquito y es dos mil 117 pesos por lo
tanto teniendo un interés compuesto
continuo después de tres años yo voy a
ver dos mil 117 pesos y así de sencillo
se acaba un ejercicio cuando tenemos
interés compuesto continuo que es cómo
funcionan los bancos porque además con
este interés continuo
yo puedo saber en cualquier momento en
cualquier año cuánto le voy a deber al
banco es decir que si yo te presto una
cierta cantidad de dinero vas a saber en
qué momento tú me vas a deber qué
cantidad y de hecho estas cantidades
crecen de una manera muy rápida por lo
tanto hay que tener mucho cuidado con
cuánto le pedimos al banco y durante
cuánto tiempo
vamos a otro ejercicio que sea un poco
más difícil supongamos esta vez que yo
le pido al banco prestado 50 pesos el
banco me va a cobrar un cierto interés
compuesto continuo a una tasa r y esa
deuda la voy a dejar correr durante 10
años y al cabo de 10 años resulta que le
debo al banco 500 pesos le debo el banco
500 pesos ahora mi pregunta es cuál era
la tasa de interés del banco a la cual
estaba mi dinero es decir yo lo que
quiero es resolver una ecuación que
ecuación bueno yo empecé con un capital
de 50 pesos y recordando la fórmula que
siempre hemos utilizado es 50 por el
elevado a la r por el tiempo es decir 50
por el elevado a la 10 r y esto es igual
a la cantidad de deuda que me origina es
decir a los 500 pesos que debo después
de sus 10 años ahora recuerden que tras
lo que voy extras r por lo tanto voy a
pasar el 50 del otro lado dividiendo 500
entre 50 me da 10 ahora bien como una
incógnita está en el exponente tengo que
aplicar de ambos lados la función
logaritmo
con la función logaritmo lo que voy a
hacer es bajar un exponente por lo tanto
el logaritmo en que base logaritmo en
base de elevado a las 10 se r es igual a
logaritmo en base de 10 lo que hago de
un lado lo hago del otro y como es un
número tan importante que tantas veces
aparecen las aplicaciones el logaritmo
en base tiene un nombre especial se le
conoce como el logaritmo natural y ojo
estoy utilizando el logaritmo en base
porque es el número que está elevado a
una cierta potencia ahora voy a utilizar
excel para calcular el logaritmo en base
o el logaritmo natural de 10 entonces
vamos a hacerlo esto es igual a
logaritmo natural de 10 y esto me da
vamos a ver
me da 2.30 28 entonces vamos reduciendo
esta ecuación logaritmo en base a
logaritmo natural de y elevado a las 10
seré bueno el logaritmo con la esteban y
solamente me queda 10 ere o dicho de
otra manera se cae el exponente y el
logaritmo natural de es igual a 1 por lo
tanto del lado izquierdo solamente me
queda 10
y bueno estos dos se eliminan logaritmo
en base de s eliminar y del otro lado me
queda el logaritmo de base es el
logaritmo natural de 10 y eso ya lo
habíamos calculado el lugar y tmo
natural de 10 era 2 punto recuerdan era
2.30 y entonces del lado izquierdo tengo
10 r aquí parece que es 10 elevado a la
guerra pero no no es 10 r es igual a
2.30 y despejar de aquí aire ya es pan
comido porque hay que pasar el 10
dividiendo y me queda que eres igual a
punto 23 o que la tasa de interés
compuesto de manera continua con la cual
una deuda de 50 pesos a lo largo de 10
años se convierte en una deuda de 500
pesos es del 23% y bueno creo que hasta
aquí voy a dejar este vídeo no sin antes
comentarles que es muy importante todo
lo que acabamos de ver y que sería muy
bueno que ustedes lo llegaran revisarán
que en efecto el límite cuando n tiende
a infinito de la expresión 1 más 1 entre
de todo esto elevado a la n en verdad
sea que esto es igual a él sería muy
bueno que ustedes probaran con varios
valores de n
vean como convergen esta sucesión y
también prueban con nuevos valores de p
los valores de r con nuevos valores de
nn en nuestra fórmula del capital que
por cierto esta fórmula del interés
compuesto continuo va a ser una fórmula
que les va a servir bastante si es que
algún día toman la decisión de
endeudarse con algún banco y bueno no se
pierdan nuestros siguientes vídeos